right now Hollywood is continuing to
ramp up their vile daily hatred campaign
against President Trump his supporters
for example this week insane Robert
DeNiro totally unhinged another vulgar
rant and of course this behavior has
been going on now for two years take a
look yes I'm angry yes I am outraged yes
I have thought an awful lot about
blowing up the White House when was the
last time an actor assassinated the
president
I'll clarify I'm not an actor
today the world is suffering from the
real Donald Trump come on let's go
what are we talking about let's clap for
that this idiot is the president the guy
is a fool come on our government today
with the prompting of our baby and chief
has been chief I call him and yet the
president has shattered one economic
record after another
unemployment straight on down the line
joining us now he is the editor-at-large
of the Daily Mail calm Piers Morgan is
with us appears by the way is in the US
hosting Daily Mail TV early today and
tomorrow pilot and your show is a
massive hit you know you're only
mistaken TV in the US was lecturing
Americans about guns which I don't want
to talk to you about we could go we
could go a long time on guns
mr. Hannity if you want but it's not
dude tonight not tonight
did you really you almost had to borrow
my shirt - come on TV - that's my gift
to you Bob as she pinged off which I'm
blaming on a rather large ribeye steak I
had earlier this evening and then they
said why don't you wear one of Sean's
unfortunately your your shirt was
obviously a much too big for me probably
because I do mixed martial arts 90
minutes of yours
oh cool uncle well it's good to see you
welcome back and grats on you you I know
you have a huge show and huge success I
love your iconoclastic nature on Twitter
although I got bored with it yeah I did
it for a while here's if I had one piece
of advice for President Trump it would
be this he can communicate on Twitter
and he reaches so many people doesn't
even need the media to communicate
didn't even need a press secretary in
the sense although I love Sarah Sanders
5% just pull back on 5% of those tweets
and he'd be golden
honestly if you took away the tweets and
the rhetoric from Donald Trump's
detractors and you actually focus on
what
actually does as president he'd be
nowhere near as scary to them as they
pretend that he is and those clips that
you play those short a really
interesting to me I've had a bugbear
about this since Trump got elected well
for two years now we've had most of the
major liberal celebrities in the world
just basically screaming in a massive
gigantic hissy fit that their choice
Hillary Clinton did not win the election
and they cannot abide the fact that
somebody like Trump a celebrity actually
like them somehow with no political
experience came through and won the
White House and you know it reminds me a
bit of the brains of debate in Britain
it's exactly the same thing where
everyone who voted Briggs it according
to all the celebrities must be stupid
and racist and sexist and so on same
debate in America and the clips you just
played I mean frankly people should be
arrested for saying some of the stuff
they were saying exact I rate bomb
threats at the White House and I've
written column after column and I've
made this point to them look you can
scream as much as you like it could be
as abusive about Donald Trump as you
want to be you can call him all the
names that you're calling him but all it
will do is empower Donald Trump it will
rally his base and as we saw with
Hillary Clinton when she played the
celebrity card so hard in 2016 it
doesn't work Taylor Swift and Oprah
Winfrey recently in the midterms both
back candidates who lost two of the
biggest stars in America with the
biggest followings it's not enough to
just be a Trump basher you have to be
offering something more and I'm just
look I'm like you sure I find the vomit
making that these stars time and again
just think it's cool and productive to
stream abuse at the president the United
States there's no respect of the office
no respect for the White House and
frankly not much respect for their own
fans many of whom will have voted for
Trump and the economic success record
low unemployment 14 states African
Americans Hispanic Americans Asian
Americans women in the workplace youth
unemployment shattering records which is
great for the people that matter that
make I think America great let me ask
you you picked up something the very few
people did Obama lost 69
between the House and Senate seats in
his first midterm Clinton 60 and Donald
Trump did something that only happened
three times on a hundred years picked up
three Senate seats yeah I again I wrote
a column for Daily Mail saying to the
Democrats look whether you like Trump or
not and I'm aware they all can't stand
the side of him
it you've got to try and beat him in
2020 if I was looking at these midterms
objectively and I would say look he
improved his majority in the Senate
right he won a lot of other races if
people didn't think he win obviously he
had a loss he lost the house but if I
was a Democrat I'd look at those results
in totality and go we got a problem in
2020 how are we gonna beat this guy who
we gonna put up against him he's a
brilliant campaigner he's doing rally
after rally his base looks rock-solid
he's got all the usual suspects
screaming at him and telling him he's an
idiot
and yet he's the incumbent White House
president and I think the odds are
something like 75% of all incumbent
presidents who run again get reelected
and if they run on a surging economy
those odds go into the mid-90s so Donald
Trump has a very very very good chance I
would say of winning the next election
if you're a Democrat stop screaming and
try and find a candidate and a message
which could actually beat him because
right now though I don't see either
they're not never gonna do you're giving
very smart sound advice they will never
follow it in the next two years we will
chronicle the insanity that continues
all right next time you're in the States
I want to invite you one to my house to
see my gun collection and how I secure
them safely I am believe in responsible
gun ownership and I'm gonna take your
shooting well we all do that but I'll
also try and convince you that when we
took away a lot of guns from civilian
hands in my country in Britain it was
successful and we haven't had a school
shooting since the 1990s
I'll convince you all right good to see
you
and congrats on all your success Piers
Morgan hosting Daily Mail TV tomorrow
morning